TO KAVANAUGH, THAT'S THE FOCUS
OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
THE LEFT IS MOVING IN LOCKSTEP
IN THEIR SLEAZY EFFORT TO
OBLITERATE NOT ONLY THE
SUPREME COURT CONFIRMATION OF
BRETT KAVANAUGH, BUT THE MAN
HIMSELF.
WE'VE SEEN ACTIVISTS CONFRONTING
SENATORS IN ELEVATORS TO STALL
KAVANAUGH'S CONFIRMATION,
CHOREOGRAPHED IMPROMPTU PRESS
CONFERENCES AND RALLIES.
HOLLYWOOD STARS STAGING THEIR
TEDIOUS WALKOUTS TO URGE THE
SENATE TO VOTE AGAINST KAVANAUG
KAVANAUGH.
AND NOW ACADEMIA HAS ENGAGED, SO
WATCH OUT.
A PROVOST DISTINGUISHED
PROJECTS, PROFESSOR AT
GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY, CAROL
CHRISTINE FAIR, EVERYTHING BUT
FAIR, TWEETED THIS LAST WEEKEND
"LOOK AT THIS COURSE OF ENTITLED
WHITE MEN JUSTIFYING A SERIAL
RAPIST ARROGANT ENTITLEMENT
WHILE FEMINIST LAUGH AS THEY
TAKE THEIR LAST GASPS.
BONUS, WE CASTRATE THEIR CORPSES
AND FEED THEM TO SWINE.
YES.
SO NO LONGER CONTENT TO INTERACT
IN EIGHT AND OUR CHILDREN,
ACADEMIC LIBERALS LIKE HER ARE
NOW ADVOCATING VIOLENCE AGAINST
CONSERVATIVES.
WHEN SHE WAS EXPOSED BY CAMPUS
REFORM, THE PROFESSOR ACCUSED
THEM OF BULLYING HER.
SHE'S A DAMSEL IN DISTRESS.
I THOUGHT THEY COULD TAKE CARE
OF THEMSELVES.
IN A BLOG POST SHE INSISTED MY
CHOICE OF WORDS IS INTENDED TO
MAKE YOU UNCOMFORTABLE BECAUSE I
AND TENS OF MILLIONS OF WOMEN IN
THIS COUNTRY AREN'T COMFORTABLE
WITH THE ONGOING WAR ON OUR
BODIES, OUR LIVES AND OUR
FUNDAMENTAL FREEDOMS.
SO HELP ME OUT HERE.
MEN SHOULD HAVE THEIR GENTIALS
GENITALS MUTILATED TO GIVE HER
CONTROL OF HER BODY.
GOING TO HAVE TO TELL ME HOW
THAT WORKS.
WHAT'S SHOCKING IS THAT
GEORGETOWN IS STANDING BY THIS
LEFT-WING NUT BAG.
ARE THESE THE JESUIT CATHOLIC
VALUES THE UNIVERSITY IS SO
PROUD OF?
RECLAIM HER COMMENTS WERE
PRIVATE AND NOT THE VIEWS OF
GEORGETOWN.
BUT THIS IS A WOMAN WHO WILL
COME ON SOCIAL MEDIA, HAS CALLED
FROM SUPPORTERS -- AND
TRUMPANZEES.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF A
CONSERVATIVE ACADEMIC, IF THERE
ARE ANY, REFERRED TO A
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIAN SUPPORTERS
AS SIMIANS OR ANYONE FOR THAT
MATTER AS A MONKEY?
SOMEONE OWES ROSEANN AN APOLOGY.
THIS DEAN, CHECK IT OUT, IS A
TRUE LEFTY HATER.
>> TRUMP, AND I WON'T USE THIS
AS PREFACE, PRESIDENT, WHAT
TRUMP HAS DONE LARGELY UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF ISRAEL HAS DONE
EVERYTHING IT CAN TO SABOTAGE
THIS IRAN AGREEMENT.
>> Laura: WE HAD TO BLOW OUT
SOME OF THOSE STICKERS ON HER
LAPTOP.
SHE CAN'T EVEN KEEP THOSE CLEAN.
AND I'M SURE TRUMP IS LOSING
SLEEP OVER THE FACT THAT SHE IS
NOT CALLING HIM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JUST AS A COMPARISON, A CATHOLIC
UNIVERSITY, ALSO IN D.C., THE
DEAN HAD THE NERVE TO QUESTION
CHRISTINE FORD'S CREDIBILITY ON
TWITTER.
HE WROTE SWETNICK'S 55 YEARS
OLD, KAVANAUGH IS 52 YEARS OLD,
SINCE WHEN DO SENIOR GIRLS HANG
OUT WITH FRESHMAN BOYS?
IF IT HAPPENED WHEN KAVANAUGH
WAS A SENIOR, SWETNICK WAS AN
ADULT DRINKING WITH, AND BY HER
ADMISSION, HAVING SEX WITH
UNDERAGE BOYS.
IN ANOTHER UNIVERSITY WOULD BE
THE VICTIM AND SHE THE PERP!
FOR THAT COMPLETELY KIND OF
FACT-BASED OPINION, THE DEAN WAS
SUSPENDED BY CATHOLIC YOU FOR
THE SEMESTER AND FORCED TO WRITE
AN APOLOGY AND HE DIDN'T EVEN
THREATEN ANYBODY'S LIFE.
BY THE WAY, A SUSPENSION WASN'T
GOOD ENOUGH, YESTERDAY ANGRY
PROTESTERS STORMED THE
UNIVERSITY DEMANDING THAT THE
DEAN RESIGN.
LIBERALS HAVE INFESTED EVERY
CORNER OF UNIVERSITY'S FROM THE
CLASSROOM TO THE ADMINISTRATION
BUILDING, WE KNOW THAT BY NOW.
AND EMBOLDENED, THEY OPERATE
ACCORDING TO THEIR OWN
RESISTANCE RULEBOOK.
AT LEAST 20 YALE UNIVERSITY
PROFESSORS SHUT DOWN CLASSES.
LAST WEEK I GUESS THAT LAW
STUDENTS COULD PROTEST
KAVANAUGH'S HEARING BOTH IN D.C.
AND ON CAMPUS.
STUDENTS WORE BLACK AND STAGED
SIT INS.
HOW ORIGINAL.
UNDERGRADS LATER MARCHED ACROSS
CAMPUS TO EXPRESS THEIR OUTRAGE.
REMEMBER, KAVANAUGH IS A YALE
ALUM, SO THIS IS PARTICULARLY
PATHETIC.
>> VERY EMOTIONAL DURING HER
OPENING STATEMENT AND TO BE
CONFRONTED WITH, THE FIRST THING
THAT SENATOR GRASSLEY SAID WAS
HE FEELS EQUALLY FOR BRETT
KAVANAUGH, HER ALLEGED
PERPETRATOR AS HE FEELS FOR
DR. FORD, WHO HAS RECEIVED DEATH
THREATS.
>> AND SHE FEELS UNABLE TO BE
SAFE EVEN IN HER OWN HOME AND
FEELS THERE NEEDS TO BE A WAY
FOR PEOPLE TO EXIT, I FIND THAT
REALLY STRIKING.
IT HAPPENED TO HER DECADES AGO
AND SHE'S STILL FEELING THE REAL
EFFECTS OF IT TODAY.
>> Laura: $75,000 A YEAR FOR
TUITION AT YALE UNIVERSITY.
AND AT HARVARD UNIVERSITY,
YESTERDAY ASSOCIATED DEAN
CATHERINE CLAYPOOL ANNOUNCED
THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH WILL NO
LONGER BE TEACHING A COURSE THAT
HE IS TAUGHT IN THE PAST AT THE
SCHOOL.
CLAYPOOL CLAIMS THAT KAVANAUGH
"CAN NO LONGER COMMIT TO HIS
COURSE ON THE SUPREME COURT."
NO WONDER.
THIS IS THE UNIVERSITY THAT LAST
YEAR, MONTH AFTER TRUMP'S
ELECTION, HOSTED A RESISTANCE
SCHOOL FEATURING LEFTIST
ACTIVISTS AND AGITATORS.
>> THE ORIGIN OF THE RESISTANCE
SCHOOL LIES IN THE ELECTION ON
NOVEMBER 8TH ON 5TH 2016 OF THE
45TH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> LIKE SO MANY OF YOU, MY
FRIENDS AND I WOKE UP ON
NOVEMBER 9TH JUST DEVASTATED.
>> SCHOOLS ARE PLACES FOR
INTELLECTUAL EXCHANGE, FOR
SOCIAL TRANSFORMATION AND YES,
WHEN NECESSARY, FOR POLITICAL
RESISTANCE.
>> Laura: $80,000 OF YOUR,
WHAT IS IT AT HARVARD?
TRUE TO FORM, STUDENTS AND
ALUMNI HAVE BEEN URGING HARVARD
LAW SCHOOL TO RESCIND
KAVANAUGH'S TEACHING APPOINTMENT
SINCE THE CHRISTINE FORD
ALLEGATIONS LEAKED.
IF HUNDREDS OF GRADUATES SIGNED
A PETITION DEMANDING THAT
HARVARD CUT TIES WITH KAVANAUGH.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE MOB GOT
THEIR WAY.
FOR YALE AND HARVARD, AND EVEN
DEAN UNFAIR, WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER, WHAT HAPPENED TO THIS
PRINCIPLE OF INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY?
I THOUGHT THE LIBERALS REALLY
BELIEVED IN THAT.
THAT'S TOTALLY OUT THE WINDOW.
GIVEN THE SHAKY STATE OF THESE
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST KAVANAUGH
AND THE DAILY EROSION OF THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE ACCUSERS, WHY
ARE LAW SCHOOLS OF ALL PLACES
RUSHING TO JUDGMENT AGAINST
THEIR OWN ALUMNUS WITHOUT ANY
SUBSTANTIATING EVIDENCE OR
WITNESSES?
IT'S AMAZING.
IF THEY REALLY WANTED TO TEACH
THEIR LAW STUDENTS AN IMPORTANT
LESSON, IT MIGHT BE THEIRS.
WHAT YOUR POLITICAL PREJUDICE
ASIDE.
EXERCISE A BIT OF RESTRAINT AND
WITHHOLD JUDGMENT UNTIL ALL THE